[Music]
yo what is up guys mkbhd here and uh as
you can see
i'm back in my car it's been about three
months
and uh you might have remembered that it
was already back in november of 2018
last year that i originally got in that
accident and didn't have my car for the
beginning of it i've been taking notes
since then on the entire process my
tesla repair process so this
is that timeline how it broke down and
why it took three months and why it
didn't take
three days or a whole year
so that day of the accident i made that
video obviously that you guys saw
detailing pretty much what exactly
happened number one rule don't stand a
truck's blind spot for too long
so after that happened i towed my car or
got it towed to the tesla service center
nearest to me in new jersey now tesla
service centers they don't do bodywork
they do other types of repairs and
technical problems and troubleshooting
and things like that but they would hold
on to it until i could tell them what
body shop to send it to because
obviously this needs body work and uh
this is usually the part where if you
have your insurance your insurance would
get a rental car for you to drive
accurate you might have seen on twitter
uh super nice they've worked with me on
the second ever autofocus video they
reached out to me before i even had the
chance to get the police report so i
could give it to the insurance so that i
could get a rental car uh so big shout
out to them they said hey if you need
any wheels while you're getting your car
replaced we'll hook you up so that's
what i've been doing i was driving an
accurate mdx which was then replaced by
they had to swap it out with an acura
rdx so they're suvs
they were fine but a crash or something
an incident that happens on the highway
in new jersey has to be filed as a
police report from state police which
since they're much slower than actual
local police took uh three weeks so the
incident was november 16th
the police report came in december 8th
so i finally get the police report
december 8th the trucker is of course
entirely found at fault so the truck
driver's insurance will be paying for
the repair of this car entirely so
that's a good step one so from there the
car gets moved to the body shop the body
shop is j b body shop it's in new york
it's relatively close
to the service center so they tow the
truck there and that's where they'll
complete the initial assessment figure
out what sort of repairs they have to do
create an estimate for how much it will
cost all that will happen there so they
completed that primary inspection on
december 24th before starting the
disassembly uh total value of the
repairs were estimated at 39
561
and 94 cents
not cheap obviously that's why i'm glad
we got the insurance part figured out
but i mean it kind of makes sense you
guys saw the initial photos like
obviously a lot of the car on the entire
left side was damaged you're gonna have
to replace parts new doors
new mirror new rear three quarter panel
the whole left side of the car basically
so now they've done the insurance
paperwork they have the estimate the
initial estimate for how much it's going
to cost they have their labor costs then
they can get started here is
i think the best part and where it
really hinged on why this took the three
months it did and why it didn't take the
nine months they could have taken so the
body shop jmb body shop they were super
legit and i could tell that like as soon
as i was walking in to pick up my car
like outside they had lamborghinis and
mclarens and and porsches and other
high-end cars and a bunch of other
teslas already sitting there they're
clearly very experienced and trusted in
performing repairs on high-end cars so i
was glad that this was the shop that we
chose but the place that this all hinged
is the body shop once they completed
that initial inspection
they were able to determine that they
had 100
of the parts needed for the repair
in stock already
so the doors the side panels all the
sort of things that needed to be
replaced they had them all in stock but
that was no accident so the key here is
so tesla has uh what you call a
certification program similar to like
apple might have a certification program
they do and so the key you can take your
tesla to like any body shop you want
theoretically like you can take your
imac to any computer store you want to
get repaired but what you'll want to do
is take your tesla to a tesla certified
body shop for that repair those body
shops have the connection to order
official parts from tesla they have the
tooling and the expertise required to do
a complete undetectable repair the way
tesla would do it in theory you could go
to somewhere else but you wouldn't have
that same experience so this body shop
jmb they are an aston martin certified
body shop and a mclaren certified body
shop and you can check out all these
other badges they have on their toolbox
so they have the tooling and the
specialization to handle these including
teslas and like i said there were some
teslas that were already there along
with apollo getting repaired
so that was the thing had they not had
all the parts in stock even one or two
things they would have to submit an
order to tesla and then wait for tesla
to ship them those official parts which
has notoriously taken
three six sometimes nine months or even
longer for certain parts to get shipped
from tesla to body shops to complete
repairs
so i was super lucky to find this body
shop that had all of the the parts
needed to do the repair and that
minimized that amount of time and they
could get right started on the repair
they actually had to do so they got
right started um by january 3rd all the
structural work was done all the
suspension and alignment and things like
that they were finished with they were
texting me to keep me up to date with
how they were doing on the car sending
me pictures which was cool
and then there were the cosmetics
so it's a wrapped car obviously you
replace it with naked parts you got to
wrap those parts too things like that so
once you've done the actual structural
work and the suspension work then they
start the cosmetic work and they even
threw in some bonuses like uh buffing
out the chipped glass and the headlights
and repairing the paint chips in my hood
in the front bumper that part i can
confirm was definitely them taking care
of me they didn't have to do all of that
they just had to do the actual repair to
the broken piece but anyway on january
14th i got another insurance adjustment
notification basically they'd had
someone come to inspect the car before
they disassembled it this was an
adjustment since they'd actually
disassembled it and done the integral
repair parts so they had an adjustment
that added
9449.65 to the cost of the repair after
the disassembly so that brought the
total to just over 49 000
of damage repaired and that includes
labor costs i actually have the bill
right here and uh you can see it that is
the uh the total estimate amount plus
the one supplement amount totals 49 000
of repairs total balance due from
customer thanks to the truck drivers
insurance cooperating zero dollars so
they finished everything by february 4th
uh and the funny part was they had
re-wrapped the whole left side with all
the new parts and then i got a text and
a picture from them saying hey look we
re-wrapped the left side but now the
wrap on the left looks like crisp and
fresh and new and the wrap on the right
it's a year and a half old so it kind of
looks like a little bit faded a little
bit warmer in color from being in the
sun do you want to just go ahead and
re-wrap the whole car so it matches and
it looks nice and clean
uh and i just said yes because i
i'd been waiting so many weeks at that
point might as well get it right might
as well finish it off so that's what
they did so february 13th i went in to
go pick it up i actually had a look at
the shop and got to meet the people who
actually worked on my car saw a bunch of
the other cars there but yeah when i
drove it off i feel like that car
basically looked just like it did the
day i got it wrapped initially clean af
and then yesterday valentine's day i got
uh i did a winter wheel swap also
because the last time i drove it i still
had the summer tires on it so it's been
that long but that's basically the
timeline the three months since november
16th it kind of seems like it flew like
it just happened but it also kind of
took forever while i was waiting for it
to come back but three months between
the incident all the repairs and getting
the car back yesterday
[Music]
i've learned a couple things one is that
i really do
like the electric car experience more
than the gas car experience and this is
no offense to gas cars obviously i don't
know who'd take offense to that but like
at a certain point i was actually
getting like disappointed that i would
wake up and the car wasn't at 100
refueled overnight like an electric car
would be still have to go to a gas
station and also i was that guy that
like got out of the car and then
realized it was still running and had to
get back in and turn it off before
leaving because obviously with these
electric cars you put it in park you get
out and it's off you're done you walk
away and it locks so just those little
things like i really appreciate those
things all over again i think my advice
that i can offer to people who are in
maybe a similar spot that i was if
you're looking to decide where to get
your car repaired number one definitely
pick a certified body shop for the
possibility of a better experience
number two if you can try to call the
body shop or get in touch with them and
figure out if they have parts in stock
and if they have the parts that you
think will be in stock maybe you got a
fender bender ask them if they have the
front bumper in stock things like that
because that made a world of a
difference i could probably still be
waiting here halfway through that repair
process if i'm still waiting for tesla
to send parts but yeah that's pretty
much it i hope you guys are able to
learn from my experience from what i've
gone through in the past couple weeks
but i am
so glad to have this back and to be
driving it daily and i'll hang out in
the comments and talk with you guys on
twitter as i usually do about this sort
of follow-ups to the story there's going
to be differences now with selling this
car and with getting different i mean
you don't want to sell a repaired car
the same way as just a regular used car
so there's all kinds of future updates
that will come from this and we'll be in
touch about that but until then
that's everything i got
thanks for watching
talk to you guys the next one
peace